My kids aren't picky eaters at all,
but they do love chicken,
so I decided to make them one of their favorite meals for dinner,
roast chicken.
I wasn't about to make a grocery trip,
so to elevate this simple go to meal,
I decided to make some homemade sourdough croutons
with the cabbage and dipping I had chopped a few days before
when the salad and dressing were prepped.
I pop the salad back in the
fridge to make sure it would be cold and crisp when I serve it,
since my husband loves it like that.
I then got started with the croutons by chopping a several day old
sourdough sandwich bread loaf into
1 to 2 inch cubes
and topping them with olive oil,
salt, thyme, and oregano.
There's for about 20 minutes
and then I finished by slicing the chicken,
which literally was falling off the bone
because it had been slow cooked all day.
I reserved the nutrient rich broth for soups and cooking.
Grains are like yams.
While my family waited at the dinner table,
I toss the salad with hot croutons and a pineapple vinaigrette
and serve dinner
with a side of purple sauerkraut
that I'd allowed to ferment for about one month.
This dinner was easy and very delicious.